broadcast is now starting all attendees
are in listen-only mode
but morning everyone and welcome to
investor Expo show for February 27th for
the last show of this winter season my
name is Anna and I'll be your host today
please take a look at your control panel
in the question box you will be able to
ask any questions you want during the
speakers presentation and also find the
helpful links from this event this
session will be recorded and sent to
your email today we are having a dream
team on our show five amazing speakers
Michael Walters TJ Watkins Norman
harlots
Joshua Martinez and dr. Barry burns I
would like to begin and bring to the
show
our first speaker Michael Watts us but
morning Michael hi Anna how are you
doing today ah perfect
excited yeah great to be here what have
you prepared for us today well today
I'll be talking about order flow
strategies that will help traders
improve their overall results
you know these markets the last
especially the last few days have been
going kind of crazy you know you turned
on the news this all this stuff with the
coronavirus is finally working on the
markets and you know some traders have
been doing well other traders that have
been struggling and you know I'm talking
about ways to use order flow you know
just to keep you on the right side of
the markets which is always a good thing
perfect I'm gonna give screen over to
you okay and get back to you around 8:45
Pacific okay just make sure you can see
my screen
are there fall strategies this viewing
probably looks good all right wonderful
thanks Anna I'll speak to you in a
little bit all right so hey everybody
it's my name is Mike Balto's from order
flows comm and I'm gonna be talking
about order flow strategies that will
improve your trading and you know I'm
gonna be sharing with you guys some
simple ways to use order flow to
recognize when the market is starting to
make a move so you get in on the move as
soon as possible I remember you know
everyone always says the trend is your
friend so you want to get in on the
trend as early as you can and more
importantly I want to show you how to
use order flow to keep you on the right
side of the market you know lately this
markets have been going berserk and a
lot of movements up and down you know
how we see the big overall trend is down
but you know it often pauses for a while
and you know traders have been finding
themselves getting chopped up in that
sideways activity and you know by the
time this presentation is over you know
if you're new to order flow and you want
to learn more I'm going to show you how
to get a copy of my book trading order
flow you're not gonna get the actual
hardbound copy you're gonna get a link
to where you can download the PDF and
print it up so for those of you that are
new to order flow and myself Michael
Balto's you know just a brief background
on Who I am just understand where I'm
coming from where I learned order flow
and you know how I used it in my career
so you know I started on the CMA floor
as a runner with Dean Witter that was in
the early 1990s eventually I left the
trading floor when electronic trading
started up I felt that was going to be
the future of the market and you know it
was the right decision after that I left
Dean Witter to join EDF man on the
global macro trading desk we know he
traded everything all the commodities in
the world after that I joined Commerce
Bank as their license your ex trader you
know I traded buns baubles schatz dax
against all the US products i was based
in chicago i was one of only if a
handful of people that had an actual ux
trading license after 9/11 I left
Commerce Bank and I took some time off
the then after about six months
after you know sort of decompressing
from the finance industry I got back
into trading with Cargill Cargill is the
big commodity trading firm in the United
States and the world you know it's a
privately held company but if it was a
public company it would probably be
ranked now probably about the third or
fourth largest company in the United
States we traded all the commodities
around the world you know not just
commodities but everything in the supply
chain including the shipping so you know
we had a very good idea of you know the
real supply and demand that was going on
in the market
after a Cargill I joined JP Morgan in
Singapore I spent eight years there as
vice president of Futures Trading after
my daughter was born I left JP Morgan
and I started writing my book and
eventually whoops I came up with the
order flows trader software that
happened in 2015 so it's going on five
years now that we've been around in the
market teaching other traders how to
read order flow and really what I
decided to do is I wanted to take all my
experience as a trader and put it into a
software platform so other traders you
know can take advantage of it because
quite honestly you know there's no
trading floors you know there's no CME
CBOT trading floor with you know a lot
of traders running around screaming that
you know someone that really wanted to
learn how to understand the market could
have a low barrier of entry now
everything is traded electronic and you
know traders trading is is a lonely
business sometimes especially you know
if you're getting started you don't know
anybody and you know I wanted to have a
software platform that traders can use
to take the analysis that professional
traders do and use it themselves now the
order flows traders and add-on for ninja
trader 8 and the track to see in this
presentation are generated from my
software the order flows trader and
basically it takes the time and sales
data the tape so to speak and puts it
into an easy-to-read format and
highlights to the trader actionable
activity in the order flow you know in
the order flow there's a lot of stuff
going through a lot of times it doesn't
necessarily mean anything but there's
going to be certain times when
something is happening in the order flow
you know big orders going through that
you know as a trader you can take
advantage of now Before we jump in you
know just a brief disclaimer you know
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor you
should only trade with risk capital you
could afford to lose anyway those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading no past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
you know basically if you can't afford
to trade if you're on a very tight
budget save up the markets are there
they're going to be there in the future
they're not going anywhere
you know take your time while you're
saving your money to start trading you
know take the time to learn right the
learning is free now you know if you
turn on the TV obviously the last couple
days you know you think that the markets
are going to go to zero but you know the
reason not to get worried is you know
the markets go up they go down right the
oh we've been through you know just in
the last you know every seems like every
ten years we have a big crisis although
understands Trump's been president and
seems like every other week we got a big
crisis but you know with big price
movements and good volume that equals
opportunity you know I of traders who
have done very well with this recent
market activity you know people that
were normally making one or two thousand
dollars a day all of a sudden are now
making three to four thousand you know
how long is this gonna last I don't know
in terms of the market volatility but
you know you have to take advantage of
it when it's there you know if you
remember four or five years ago you know
most of the day most of the time in the
SPS would have ranges of you know 15
points 20 points would be considered a
big range day now we're doing that you
know times three times four times five
you know we're getting a hundred point
ranges in the e-mini S&P S which is
pretty big and coronavirus impeachment
Soleimani strike going to war with iran
iraq you know the trade war china that's
just this year right it's the news comes
so fast and furious that you know it's
almost like every Sunday night when the
markets real
you know everyone is all worried that
the markets you know the world's gotta
come to an end
and it's only February right you know we
got the election in November so I'd
imagine there's probably gonna be a lot
more rollercoaster ride in the market
right but you know don't don't fall into
this thing that oh my gosh you know this
is out or you know this happened that oh
my god you know the world's gonna you
got to be worried about it you know
trade the market don't necessarily trade
the news trade what the markets telling
you you know traders are panicked you
know I know a lot of people say oh my
gosh you know this is the beginning of
the end you know I know people literally
every Sunday night market opens up lower
and they think this is the beginning of
the bear market they've been saying that
since last year every Sunday night but
yet to understand what's happening in
the market as it happens right you have
to be a proactive trader one who
actively reviews the market's conditions
their structure and overall trend you
know don't let emotions News reports the
talking heads on TV
don't let them influence you you know
you have to sort of put them aside block
them out while you're training you know
trading decisions are made based on
current supply and demand movements at
chrony on the market the market doesn't
move because price hit a moving average
or we cross the oscillator across zero
you know it moves on supply and demand
you know and that's how people and
traders decide how much something is
worth and the best way to know what
something is worth is to see how much
traded the volume at a price now if
looking on a normal bar chart right your
normal candlestick chart you can't tell
that right you just see what price
opened what the high the low and we're
closed for that period is you know
you've got to be Superman basically you
need to have x-ray vision to see in the
market but if you have a chart that
takes that information it just goes into
a normal bar chart but puts it into an
easy to read format right like a volume
footprint then everything is going to be
revealed to you
you know it's imagine it's like playing
cards playing poker but being able to
see the other players hands right so you
know what they have you know before you
decide to stay in the hand gives you the
advantage over other people that are
just looking at a normal bar chart
however you know looking at the order
flow you have to know what to look at
you know you have to know you have to
understand you know how to use the
different data points in order flow to
your advantage and there are three key
data points in order flow that you need
to know Delta imbalance and point of
control and I'll just explain everyone
just really briefly
you know Delta is the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in that bar and if there's
positive Delta and that means buyers are
in control there's negative Delta
sellers are in control what do I mean by
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
well if the market is you know markets
trade into a auction so there's a bid
there's an offer but the price isn't
going to move unless somebody buys the
offer to move the price higher or sells
the bid to move the price lower the
person who buys the offer or sells into
the bid that is the aggressive trader
and when you have more aggressive
traders on the
by side and you have what's called
aggressive buying and you have positive
Delta if you have more people selling
into the bed the bid you can end up with
negative Delta and you're actually going
to have sellers are in control now the
next point is imbalances and again it
occurs in the two-way auction between
the volume traded on the bid versus the
volume traded on the offer and if it's
greater than four to one generally some
people use different ratios you know
some people use three to one others use
ten to one then you consider it an
imbalance so imagine you know you have
yeah ugh a war fight you know you got
two people on one side you got ten
people on the other side both pulling
the rope which side do you think it's
gonna win it's gonna you know the side
that it's got the ten people is going to
win right because that's imbalance right
the the battle between two versus ten is
you know it's it's out of whack now the
third point of order flow is point of
control and it's simply the price level
in the bar where the most volume traded
and what makes it unique is that it can
act as supply and demand over the next
bar or bars right and what I mean by is
just the price level in the bar with
most volume traded well you take the
volume that at a price level the volume
is trading on the bid the volume traded
on the offer you add it up if that price
level in the bar has the most volume
that's your point of control generally
it will occur somewhere towards the
middle of the bar you know cuz you know
you got to think of equal distribution
but they don't always occur in the
middle of the bar sometimes they occur
in the middle sometimes they occur at
the extreme edges or sometimes they
occur in the in the top you know top
quarter or bottom quarter they could
pair anywhere in a bar and oftentimes
where they appear in a bar is very
revealing information to a trader so
when you put Delta imbalances and point
of control together you see the shifts
in supply and demand more easily right
the problem is now in your rear view
mirror of how to figure out what the
shifts what's happening in supply and
demand because now you have the solution
by looking at Delta imbalances and point
of control
now this is our order flow chart okay
and this is snps this is yesterday 'man
'yes this is a one-minute chart
market made that new hi there at
thirty-one seventy five and a quarter
that immediately sold off and sold off
about 20 points okay but if you're
looking at a bar chart you know you're
not getting much information but if
you're looking at an order flow chart
what do you see well when we made that
new high if we look at the Delta Delta
will appear along the bottom of the
chart we see that you got negative Delta
up around the high all right you see
selling imbalances coming in just after
the high is made and more importantly
you also see lower points of control in
each bar as we start moving away from
the high so think about it the market
was exhibiting strength as it rallied
right but after it made the new highs
it's now exhibiting signs of weakness
right the market went from a demand
driven market to a supply driven market
a market went up you know demand was
there everyone was happy to buy it hit
this level all of a sudden new supply
came into the market new sellers came
into the market and the market dropped
right that's why I talked about when you
know understanding supply and demand and
and how you can see it in the order flow
okay so this is e minis again you know
right after that move up we started
coming off right there's kind of a
choppy swing low that we put in you know
you can see you got red bar green bar
red bar green bar red bar green bar
you know it's uh you know it's
frustrating as a trader this is where
traders you'll get chopped up in this
sort of back-and-forth activity and you
know as a trader you sort of want to get
a grasp of okay what's going on you know
imagine you know it's it's like you see
the those those movies right from the
1940s where the guy flies the you know
the airplane the propeller airplane up
then he's going up and up office when
the engine kills it just dies and it
starts falling down he's thinking oh my
god you know he's pushing all the knobs
you know trying to figure out what's
happening before the engine starts up
and
it's the same way with with the markets
right you oftentimes you get the market
is very choppy and you don't know which
ways up which ways down and then you're
looking for some signs and you'll see it
in the order flow right and so if you
see the two boxes down at the bottom of
the chart that's the Delta alright we
see the Delta starting to put in some
signs of life starting to get strong
right right before this rally up right
the first box you know you had 481 498
markets started putting a little bit of
rally some selling came back in then the
Delta started growing again
you know 73 to 70 2300 as the market
finally righted itself you know it had
that false start a little bit earlier
couldn't get the third positive Delta in
there finally it hit that level where
the buying came back in you're seeing
buying imbalances in the bars you're
seeing the points of control migrate
higher no you know oftentimes you know
on choppy market market volatile markets
you put in these nice v-shape turns in
the market and you know yesterday again
it was one of those type of days but if
you're watching what's happening in the
market you know watching the Delta
watching the points of control in the
market then you sort of have your your
thumb your your fingers on the pulse of
the market as to what's happening all
right we put in this nice v-shaped
bottom you know but when we put in that
bottom there 10:14 right in the middle
we don't know that that's gonna be the
bottom you're gonna look for some signs
in the order flow that may the bottom
has been made now we're starting to
rally and what do you see well you know
on the way down you're seeing selling
the balances as if the low you start
seeing buying imbalances come in more
importantly you're starting to see the
positive Delta come in in each bar
having positive Delta
you're starting to see the points of
control migrating higher and I go a
little bit more in depth into the points
of control a little bit a little bit
later but you know you're putting those
three together you could understand that
you know the low is being put in and now
we're starting to move away from that
low the buying is coming in right we've
gone from a supply driven market as the
market went down to a demand driven
market as demand is coming into the
market and we start rallying so this is
gold okay and we're just going sideways
right in this box here we're going
sideways for about 15 minutes you know
and actually it's longer than that prior
we're also going sideways but there's
there's no real catalyst in the market
to tell you hey that this market is
getting ready to start moving higher or
lower but if you're watching the Delta
as you're coming towards the end of this
sideways activity although at this you
know you don't know what the market is
moving yet but you could just see the
Delta is starting starting to string
together bars with positive Delta you
know before you'd get one or two bars
with positive Delta one or two bars with
negative Delta but nothing concrete then
you know towards the end the last six
bars all five of them are positive Delta
once negative Delta more importantly in
the circle you see three bars there with
higher points of control right and
that's that's important as I'll explain
later now this is crude oil yesterday
you know it's funny how crude oil has
come off quite a bit but I went to get
gas but it seemed to be higher than it
was a few weeks ago but you had a
hundred points sell off 100 you had a $1
sell off you know a hundred ticks in the
crude and
you want to get into these moves as soon
as possible right unfortunately you know
a lot of the ways people approach the
market they're getting in late
you know Fibonacci okay I love I'll be
honest you know I've very early on in my
career by about five or six years into
my career there was a floor trader as he
levy taught me about Fibonacci and even
you wanted me to work for him but I just
couldn't at the time and he taught me
the importance of looking at these
retracements so you know in the back you
know I always still look for certain
levels you know 50% 38% 61% however you
know you got to realize you know the
world doesn't revolve around Fibonacci
right you don't go to the barbershop and
you know they need to ask you how you
want your haircut I'll just take 38.2
off on the side 23.6 in the back no you
know I want to cut like this right when
you cook yeah you don't you don't the
recipes don't say you know put in 38.2%
of salts
you know the TSP you know you put in a
teaspoon or something
but nevertheless you know 50% is a
respectable level you know and it's it
the markets do react around 50% 38% and
61% so if you're a Fibonacci trader okay
and you come back here right off the
high to the swing low it pulls back
about 50% around the 5012 area yeah it
gives you a great shorting opportunity
excuse me and then you know you get
short around the fifty twelve area you
know it makes the move down to 49 you
know 50 49 40 you know that's that's a
nice trade okay
now you know if your traditional headers
you know technical analysts you got a
nice head and shoulders formation here
right but if you trade head and
shoulders you know you got to break the
neckline right and you're gonna measure
down you know the distance from the head
to the neckline you know down below
which also works out to about you know
around the 4940 area again you know
another nice trade you know you hear
you're catching 40 you know 40 cents 50
cents you know on the 50% retracement
you know you're catching about 70 70
cents you know that we need a decent
trades but where would you rather be
short from the 50 40 area the 50 10 area
or the 49 88 area right well you know
you're gonna want to be short from as
high a level as possible and order flow
if you were watching the order flow
yesterday when you hit that high there
were some very negative signs in the
order flow that this market you know is
getting ready to potentially sell off so
what were the signs well
at the high there's what I call a ratio
and divergence right divergence is a new
or equal high with negative Delta you
know a ratio is something that's unique
to my software that you know calculates
the order flow in the bar right and
there's gonna be bearish ratios it'll
appear above the bar and a blue number
or below the bar if it's a bullish ratio
in a blue number if it's just a black
number that's just your normal order
flow going through but you know even if
you don't have my software even if
you're just using a plain old regular
order flow chart what's happening in the
Delta on the move up
you're looking at predominantly negative
Delta you know you get a few bars with
some positive Delta's you know here was
a nice strong positive Delta of 884 as
you make that new high you know by a
tick you follow it up with a new high by
another ticket just go sideways before
you get that bearish sign in the order
flow now what else though but as you
going up into the high it's negative
Delta you hit the high still negative
Delta's start coming off the high more
negative Delta Supply has coming into
the market right and that's important
information that you know if you're
looking at a bar chart you're probably
not going to notice now
here's more of a bigger picture of that
footprint so you can see you know from
earlier going into the high till after
the high is made you got that little bit
of a pullback towards the high and keep
selling off you got weak Delta going
into the high when the high is made and
after the high is made now I give you a
tip right institutional traders don't
wait for the high to be made and then
start selling right they what they're
doing you know they recognize you know
they're they're institutional traders
are involved in the market in ways that
retail traders aren't you know in and no
disrespect or anything like that but you
know what what I mean is you know
they're they're often got other deals
going on in the physical market you know
and things like that that you know
they're going to know these levels of
resistance or support better than the
most retail traders but the point is as
a market is rallying institutional
traders are selling into that rally
because that's going to give them the
opportunity to move more supply right
they don't wait till the market makes a
high and say oh you know hey we made a
new high and then they start selling
theirs they're already there you know
that there are three steps ahead of you
they realize that you know we're coming
up to this level I know that at this
level this this and this you know is
going to be overpriced because of these
other factors they start selling as the
market is making that high once that
high is that's why you see all the
negative Delta is going up into the high
because they keep hitting those bins
there people are still excited you know
hey we're going higher in the crude I
better start buying well they're buying
who are they buying it from you know
they're buying it from the you know the
the big oil companies and the big
traders out there that know that you
know hey at around this 40 45 area you
know it's a great opportunity to short
this so you know there's a lot of
information in the order flow as you're
coming up and making this high that's
bearish right now once you start selling
off you know you sell off this box the
first box is the 50% fib level
second box is the Head & Shoulders trend
line area but look at that that whole
time it's still all negative Delta I
mean those are legitimate places to sell
but what would you rather sell you know
30 cents higher than the 50% fib level
you know 50 cents higher than the Head &
Shoulders trend line break you're gonna
want to sell as as high as possible an
order flow gives you that ability to see
what's happening in the market even
before you hit those those levels now
Delta's going to hell
you see shifts in supply and demand
right Delta it's gonna help you see when
a market is transitioning from demand
driven market to a supply driven market
you know open when a market has been
moving up to one assorted stalls and
starts moving down you know supply is
coming into the market or vice versa
right from a supply driven market to a
demand driven market you know everyone
is distributing supply getting rid of
everything but all of a sudden it's such
a low price that demand starts coming in
people saying hey you know what I could
start buying it you know perfect example
this coronavirus right facemasks you
know face masks a joke becoming a new
Bitcoin you know prices have have I'll
say skyrocketed but doubled tripled and
it's very difficult to find them if you
go to stores you know I noticed this
back in in January I started buying face
masks you know exciting but I've got
three kids and you know obviously my
wife but I started noticing that
scarcity even on Amazon you know a lot
of them were sold out and why it's
because of demand demand is there now
prices are going higher everyone is
running you know their scarcity the
supply is lessen and demand is greater
that's why prices are going up you know
some of these face masks you know back
in January you could buy a box for you
know eight dollars now you know you're
paying twenty bucks a box now I'm going
to show you a quick way to determine if
markets coming out of consolidation and
starting a trend okay and it deals with
point of control game remember point of
control is simply the price level in the
bar or the most volume traded like I
said it can act as supply and demand
over the next bar or bars now thing to
remember right every bar has a point of
control it's just the you know there's
no fancy math involved here there's no
calculus or anything it's just simple
arithmetic the price level in the bar
with the most volume you know people
like to try and make things complicated
it doesn't need to be complicated it's
important because in a basic sense it
helps a trader determine where value is
in a bar right we don't often times we
look at the market on a bar by bar basis
right volume profile is nice I have
volume profile I use volume profile but
as a trader it's better to have a grasp
of what's happening now where
value is now rather than the value for
the day because you know we may not come
back to the day's value area you know so
it's you know on a trendy market market
that's that's moving higher
right I know value is at 45 but we're
trading 65 well okay yeah I know value
is at 45 over trading 20 points higher I
can't do anything really with that I
want to know where value is you know on
a much tighter timeframe it was much
smaller time frame and how you're gonna
see it is on the points of control now
like I said each bar has a point of
control right so there's this phrase
that I use is called migrating points to
control and really what I'm looking for
is three points of controls moving in a
certain direction you know three green
bars three up bars three green candles
each one with the higher point of
controls tell me the market is moving
higher if I have three red bars and each
bar has a lower point of control than
the previous bar it's telling me the
markets moving lower so take a look at
this right this is emitting is this a
train chart markets sold off they start
to put in a little rally okay then one
sideways okay fine
well I'm curious to know what's going to
happen are we going to continue this
little rally back up or we're going to
continue back down are we gonna come out
of this sideways action and go up or
come out and go lower well if I'm
watching the points at controls of
course I could also watch the deltas I
see Delta's getting negative as we're
coming out of this box here the sideways
box but more importantly I see the
points of control I got a red bar red
bar red bar each bar a lower point of
control obviously I got sound imbalances
as well which you know helps so you know
this is gonna give me a very high
confidence trade right that because I
know that I can combine I got lower
points of controls
I've got selling imbalances in the bars
I've got negative Delta and it's getting
stronger minus 2 48 minus 3 28 minus 579
that this move is going to go down right
and and we do all right we do sell off
from 52 down into the the mid 40s
over the next
three four minutes okay now here's again
something similar right we started
making this move up you know we weren't
who were going sideways came us or below
this sideways activity started rallying
I got three bars up each bar higher
points of control the deltas
yeah 86 - 33 - 187 I got some pine
imbalances okay fine you know I'm
convinced maybe this markets gonna go
higher but was it do it just starts
going sideways Oh God
you know this is the part that kills
traders you know you could be correct on
your market direction but then it goes
sideways and you know you sort of then
you got to go through the whole trade
management thing oh my gosh I stay in
the trades I get out of the trade then
later guys you start coming out of this
you know the sideways activity you're
still in here
I see three bars three bars up I see I
got positive Delta which is a good sign
I see points and controls each bar
higher than the previous bar so I know
that this market has a good chance to go
much higher and we do we go from the the
43:44 area back up into the 53 area okay
same thing going sideways right and I
get the three bars here positive Delta
getting stronger 73 to 72 three zero
five I see higher points control in each
bar obviously I see buying imbalances
you know one bar has got three nice ones
got to the next one's got six you know
so it's telling me hey you know that
there's more to this move just look for
this market to go higher it does I hit
these two areas where I got two red bars
it doesn't necessarily mean the move is
over because I got a red candle right we
can't even put together more than two
did you have lower points of control but
then you know there's no third bar there
there's no third bar and then on the
next one
and we still continue keep going higher
so how would I use it you know if I was
long in the trade and on a multiple
position contract you know I might take
some off here
or here you know it depends on on your
training style so you know just to recap
what to look for is in the migrating
points controls is three green candles
up with higher each with a higher point
control than the previous one for a by
for a cell it's three red down candles
each with a lower point of control okay
you know this is simple right this is 10
years right a very liquid market a great
market if you want to trade sighs you
know I know some guys that they just
they trade this market you know their
clip size is a hundred contracts they
only need to make one or two ticks a day
and then they're done period but watch
this it's very slow moving market
because the volume is so heavy you know
here you got one two three on the on the
Left pauses goes the sideways starts
grinding a bit higher another three as
we go in higher right you hit the low of
the day right this red line down here is
the low of the day then you start
marching up higher points of control
right you got a primary point of control
which I'll talk about in a minute and
then you start marching back up again
all right so it's it's information
that's telling you obviously we got
positive Delta is there which is also a
good sign on the second one you see
multiple you see buying imbalances come
in which is a good sign in the 10 years
because you know the day trade such
heavy volume that sometimes it's
difficult to get a lot of imbalances now
there are times when point of control
access support or resistance right and
we call these prominent point of
controls and the order flows trader
software will highlight them on a chart
remember earlier what I said about point
of control being potential support or
resistance right this is why I created
my software's because I wanted the
software to show me where these areas of
support and resistance where these areas
where these points that controls that
really matter are appearing right I used
to do this in my head actually but I
realized you know there's a certain sort
of equation that goes into it but what
we do is we highlight them you know blue
cyan color action
for support or magenta for resistance
right and you can see here right the
blue circles are all the supportive
points of control prominent point of
control the magenta is the resistance
right so you can see how the market
reacts when we hit those levels now like
I said you know volume profile is a
great tool right and there's a lot of
people I know that use it but you know I
want to know what's happening right now
right it's it's nice to see where the
day's value area is where the days point
of control is but you know as a as a
trader who's trading right now what's
happening you know if we're 20 points
away from the point of control on a
daily basis that doesn't do me any good
I need to know I need something that's
going to tell me where the value area is
right now and the points of controls do
that for me right and like I said you
know the primary point of controls
tell me these areas where there is
support or resistance right now based on
the order flow so you can see here eight
range is a crude oil chart you get the
red circles are the bearish points of
control you see how the markets just
react right off this now this you know
when it forms on the bar right if it's a
prominent point of control it will color
it in as soon as it happens obviously if
the conditions changed during the bar
formation it will go away and once the
bar is closed
it won't reprint it won't change but
it'll appear there in real time as the
bar is trading as long as the conditions
are met so I know that as this bar is
forming you know I see this bearish
point of control forming you know and I
see we're trading you know starting to
come off and I'm ready that you know if
this market if this bar closes this next
bar you know I'm I'm looking to get
short right away
it's another example a prominent point
of control acting and support you know
sometimes people get all caught up in
support and resistance thinking there's
got to be one price level it's not right
support especially if you're looking at
a support area or a resistance area and
the market moves away comes back to it
it doesn't just come right back to the
tick oftentimes you know if you're
pulling back especially you know you're
pulling back 10 20 points to an area it
doesn't often just stop right on a dime
it's something especially in these
markets that are moves are over
exaggerated it will overshoot it by a
couple of ticks but you can see here
right my primary point of control market
comes right back to it gets through it
by a few ticks but then keeps going back
up right it hits that support area
now you know when you put some of these
things together you know prominent point
of control migrating pocs yeah you can
get in on moves very very early as you
can see here right you have your low of
the day you got a prominent point of
control you got the my gradient points
of control markets you know wants to go
up pulls back down pulls back to this
second prominent point of control the
low of this bar is the previous
prominent point of control your support
area yeah then the market pops back up
it comes back in puts a higher prominent
point of control in doesn't pull back as
close to the low then you're seeing the
migrating points of control so you know
at this low area and again I'm not even
taking to account the deltas which you
know are kind of mixed honestly I'm not
going to say that oh yeah these are very
bullish you know they're kind of mixed
honestly but by looking at the point of
controls I know their support in this
market right I know that you know if I'm
looking to buy I've got support I can
sort of hide behind it's gonna give me
you know potentially you know a much
lower risk basically because I know that
I've got support here that if this
support breaks down you know you got to
get out of the trade so you know point
of control can help keep you on the
right side of a move it's gonna help
alert you when the move is stalling it's
gonna let you know when the move is over
you know so for fixing this is euro
currency yesterday right nice move up
right then what happens start moving
down as you start moving down what's the
sign that you're moving down lower
points of control in each bar right you
have this nice demand driven market goes
stops supply comes into the market
starts getting distributed supply is
still there and it helps drive the
market lower wheat okay I just want to
you know show you another market besides
you know crude oil or emini x' is wheat
you know we grain markets are great
markets for trading with order flow
because you're the really supply and
demand driven market so here right off
the low of the day
we've got migrating higher points of
control we've got multiple imbalances
obviously we got positive deltas and you
know over the next well this is a
five-minute chart over the next 1 2 3 4
5 6 bars we make a move from 531 up to
you know 536 so it's a nice move
so hopefully by now you can see how
order flow can easily identify trade
direction and by understanding who's
clearly in control at a particular time
during trading you can find low risk
high opportunity trades but more
importantly you know order flow is going
to help you get into trades sooner
rather than later
which gives you potential for more
profits right that's why we trade is to
make money you know we don't trade
necessarily too for the exercise you
know we do it because we want a better
life we do it because we want to give
back to society in the sense of you know
making you know donations charity etc
don't overcomplicate trading you know
keep trading simple alright and an order
flow is trading to me in its simplest
sense so you know if you're interested
in learning more about order flow you
get my book go to order flows calm slash
book dot html' and it's going to take
you this page you have to enter your
name and email hit submit then the next
page is going to pop up the box the PDF
that you can download okay don't search
your email for it it's not going to come
out in the email it's going to after you
enter that information it takes you
right to the next page now if you're
interested in the software right because
by now you can see how just one piece of
order flow the point of control it's
going to give you great trading
opportunities but you know if say Mike
you know I'm interested in your software
I watched its presentation I want to
learn more about it go to order flows
calm slash special that HTML all my
pages have that HTML on the end and it's
going to do you know there's a special
deal for everybody on the software now
you know if you're not convinced that my
software you know other people have been
writing great things about it you know
there's Sheila rights you know the order
flows trader software is remarkably
helpful I can clearly see now what's
happening in the market like for example
who's in control of the market on a very
specific time and who's getting weaker
as well so again you know if you're
interested in the software it's order
flows calm slash special that HTML they
get my book
go to order flows calm slash book dot
html'
so let's not back to you Anna you know I
sort of ran out of time for questions
but um you know uh if there's questions
you know people just send me an email my
cat order flows calm and you know I'll
do my best to get back to you
you know today on your question so Anna
if you're there I'll come back to you
thank you so much it was a great
presentation and we love your books and
especially this specials first day thank
you
thank you